Ngày hay bà làm thăm mười, tầm thống Mỹ đúng nên tròm tên bố tăng thêm mười phần chăm thuy nhất khấu,
đối với hàng hòa tịch cả nader sau khi chỉ trích gai gát một quảng gà,
rồi chỉ quyền bằng của tài rô phát hành và phát sống trong trận mở mạnh giải bọn trầy
nhàng emy, Wall Street.
Đóen video sử dụng hình anh và giọt nói của cố tầm thống Mỹ Rowland Regan.
Được các gép để thế hiện sự phản đối các chính xác áp thuy nhất khấu,
nhá trân cáu buộc quảng cảo này, xuyên tạm nghiệm trọng thống điệm con greek chiếc quyền hệ tài.
Ông trăm đang liên trên mạng xấu ở trước xấu dòng việc ứng tài rô bận để video phát sống là hành động thủ địch
và tên bố sẽ tăng thuy thêm mười phần chăm sau với mức hệ này để đặc trả.
Thuyến bà, ứng tài rô lực phò cho biết đã chào đổi với thủ tường mắc cảni và sẽ tạm dương chỉ có cảo
tương ngày hành bị tạm thống mười để giảm càng thang.
Mời đường cho việc nối lại đảm phản thân mại.
Ông cảni khẳng định các bạn đã đá vận sả xả đổi thoại mạng tình xây dân và hí vọng sớm khối phục khật lắc tình tài sống phương.
Tuy nhiên tọng trăm cho biết chưa có kế hoa khách gặp lại thủ tường.
Cái này, giù cả hai giúp kiến cùng thăm dự hội đi ASEAN tại Malaysia và tình tựa.
Huyện cho gió các mặt hàng chua gần tính mức thời mời sống dời chuyên gia kinh báo.
Đi pháp này có thể tất cả mạng đến ngành thép và nhóm của các bạn đã vốn đã chuyện mức thế cao từ đồng năm nay.